NARRATOR: I met so many
families, moms and dads,
brothers and sisters, all
adjusting to a new normal
when a child tells them I'm
not a boy or I'm not a girl.
But as the saying goes,
it takes a village.
So I wondered, how
are the institutions
who help raise our
children adapting
to this gender revolution?
Grammar schools, daycare,
and that rite of passage--
summer camp.
So I traveled to Long Island
to meet Sadie, a tiny camper
on the front lines.
She's on a gender
journey of her own
and the entire community here
at Hampton Country Day camp
is along for the ride.
Will you show me around?
Sure.
OK.
Low ropes, ooh.
Oh, this is like
a zip line, right?
Yeah.
That's so cool.
So Sadie is the first
transgender camper here
at Hampton Country Day Camp.
Yes.
Has it been a big adjustment?
Were you worried about her
making this transition,
because she started
here as a boy?
Well it initially
took me by surprise.
I think through conversations
and just looking at it
in a rational way and trying to
figure out how this was going
to work out and knowing Sadie as
such a wonderful little child,
just a happy child.
This is camp, camp
is about being happy.
So our concerns were really
how Sadie was going to make
the transition here
and how other campers
were going to receive her.
So there were a number
of things to consider.
It was never a question
of would we do this,
it was just a matter
of how will we do this.
Never a question?
Never a question.
So how old were you,
Sadie, when you said--
when you thought
to yourself and you
started telling your mom and
dad, I'm not a boy, I'm a girl.
I think when I was little.
When you heard
from Sadie's parents
that she was going to be coming
to camp as a girl at six,
were you surprised?
I wasn't because I had
been speaking to her mother
even at the age of three.
I think a lot of people
listening to this conversation
might think, that's
just too young.
How do you know, at such a young
age, that this is who you are?
And could it just be a phase.
I think that's probably--
That is the question.
--What people ask.
I just use the facts
that have been given to me
and that is children
actually formulate a gender
identity at a very young age.
And it can be as
young as two or three
that they begin to demonstrate.
This is exactly
what we saw in Sadie
when she was here at camp.
And you have to allow them to
express themselves freely and
be the people that they are.
The seminars that we've attended
and we go to camp conferences,
there had already been a
lot of discussion going on.
Sleepaway camps are now starting
to consider these situations.
And started to educate ourselves
a little bit about this,
because we knew that we're
on the horizon of change.
And And tell me about other
campers and their parents.
Was that tricky?
I called every person who had
a child that was going to be
in Sadie's group
two summers ago,
giving them the
information about what
we were planning to do.
So what was the reaction?
Was there any resistance
from family members?
It was amazing.
They were so
welcoming to the idea.
I was actually surprised
by how easy it was.
Sadie was in a boys
group at age five
and then a girls group
as Sadie at age six.
How did the campers react?
The campers were
just welcoming to her.
There were certain steps
that we took to make sure
that her privacy was respected
and that the privacy of the
other campers was respected.
So her changing was
handled separately.
And you asked
Sadie's parents, you
need to have a bathing
suit that affords her more
modesty than maybe other girls.
Exactly.
I know you went shopping
for a bathing suit this year.
For a girl's
bathing suit, right?
Was that exciting for you?
Mm hmm.
Yeah?
Tell me about your bathing suit.
I think, really, I liked it.
And I was like, that was the
best shopping in my life.
And when Sadie changes she
goes to a private area.
She goes to a
separate area to change,
she's taken by a counselor,
which she loves to do,
and they go to a
separate bathroom
and she changes
in that bathroom.
In a very short
amount of time,
it seems that our
perception of gender
has changed dramatically.
There's so much going
on around this issue.
And people can just be
accepting of who people are
and give them an opportunity
to express themselves.
She's joyous.
I mean, this is a joyous child.
How could we ever take
that away from her?
Make her feel shameful
for who she is?
It just doesn't
seem right or fair.